the only clue I'll give you for tomorrow
is that Enron if you remember had a fake
trading room they were touring people
around the Enron campus I remember was
an auditor or whatever to talk about the
trading operation they actually set up
workstations and had people sitting
there looking like they were trading
remember that it's hard to remember us
okay that's my biggest clue for tomorrow
okay that was those biggest clue yet
bill is saying now his presentation was
overhyped let me jump ticking say wasn't
it bill over hyping it yeah I mean he's
basically saying my bad I'm the one who
overhyped it uh you know I was trying to
bring people to the webcast trying to
make sure they showed up they got
they're looking for a body as Ackman
says looking for a smoking gun and it
wasn't there instead they got a
three-hour you know wonky regulatory
sort of presentation that that investors
just clearly decided was not what they
were promised the day before but he was
successful in the fact that he got 11
thousand eyeballs watching this
presentation didn't he yeah he did he
got eleven thousand people that watched
it he also has gotten you know some
40,000 different looks at the
presentation online since then 143
countries are represented I mean
countries as far as Nepal one person
logged on there so you know in talking
to him he seems proud of the fact that
he was able to bring a large audience
but perhaps regretful that he you know
over spoke it before him but look it's
the law of the jungle and television
just as it is in webcast if you bring a
large audience to a show and that's what
this was that amounts to a whole lot of
nothing they're not coming back next
time does that mean that we won't have
to witness and suffer through any more
three-hour wonky regulatory
presentations well I'll say this he is
he seems no less committed to the ideas
that they raised at that conference he
seems he believes that nutrition clubs
are a signal that that people are there
for the business opportunity not for the
actual products so he's going to
continue that case for
it clear so in other words he knows like
the substance is as solid as ever it's
just the style part that he got wrong
that's exactly right as he called it it
was a it was a PR disaster PR mistake
and he lays it on his own shoulders I
mean I asked him well you know you've
got a lot of people working for you on
the PR side did you ask their advice and
he said look I'm my own worst enemy
then who is his banker one would think
in this scenario maybe not his publicist
but who's his banker his advisor his
consigliere who would advise him in
these types of things because it does
seem like the cheese is standing alone I
mean he's got a number of shops you know
including Rubenstein that's working for
him but you know all indications are
from him and you know I spoke to
Christine Richard as well and and she
said look bill does it his own way so
there's a real feeling here that bill
sort of I mean as we know he he sort of
marches to his own drum beat licks in
hand and that's all and you know he's
very vocal about his case and and in a
lot of ways you could probably find
issues with sort of how he's gone about
at PR wise but he seems to not and all
be backing away from that other than to
say that the message at that
presentation last week was lost because
of what he promised before Dwayne you
mentioned Christine Richard she's a
former colleague of ours here at
Bloomberg she became an independent
researcher and bill himself says that
she's the person who put him up to the
idea of the Herbalife short in the first
place you quote her in your story as
saying that the combination of the
overhyping of the presentation and the
length buried some of the material and
that's pretty similar to what you got
from Bill himself isn't it significant
though that somebody who is advising
bill and presumably is on his payroll is
criticizing him in this way yeah she
seems to be I mean what she's doing and
you know I spoke with her first actually
and then that led to you know wanting to
get get more from Agnon what she's
basically saying is that it's a shame
that this great research that this case
that they laid out was completely lost
because of the hype because of the stock
you know share price
surely game hold on she is the person
who originally gained build this idea so
let's just put into context who's saying
it's a shame that this great research
was overlooked she is so she's saying
but look we presented this case no one
is really pressing she was she took
issue with analysts and investors who
for instance on the conference call for
herbal life Sterling's this week didn't
you know ask a lot of probing questions
about some of that material so she's
taken it as they've largely ignored what
is in their view a very important
question so they're trying to get the
word out look we stand by this research
he put out a release two days ago and
now they're saying don't let the fact
that we messed up on the PR side
overshadow the fact that there's some
real interesting questions here that we
laid